talking about regeneration um if you  could bring regeneration to sherlock  what would that be like what would you  do oh i wouldn't bring regeneration to  sherlock that's that that show is about  uh  benedict cumberbatch and martin for even  if either of them were unwilling to do  it we would be unable to do the show  that's as simple as that um you know  there are other sherlock holmes in the  world god knows but uh that show is  about those two men without question  or moriarty oh he's dead he hurt himself  in the face  they didn't fake suicide at each other  that would just  that would be dysfunctional were you  kidding too i was kidding oh no  let's do it again let's try hanging next  time i'll be guillotined  you